senior correspondent Casey Stegall live
at the Border in Eagle Pass Texas Casey
you'll get us started
Harris good morning cbp's new fiscal
year that you were talking about did
just begin on October the 1st and agents
tell Fox that in that time there have
been at least
137 of what you were just talking about
those known godaways against 73 thousand
of them in November alone for context
CBP recorded 600 000 of them for all of
last fiscal year again migrants border
patrol know illegally enter the country
but Escape meantime this was the scene
this morning here in Eagle Pass yet
another large group this one more than
250 people mainly from Cuba and from the
Dominican Republic so you throw in the
numbers that we know about the known
apprehensions and everything's through
the roof November's official tally has
not been released but October we know
yielded more than 230 thousand
encounters that's a nearly 40 percent
increase from the previous October and a
nearly 220 percent increase from two
years ago
so I continue to say A you defend the
border and you save lives you have a
safe uh you control the border and
secure the Border you actually will save
lives not just of Americans but of the
migrants themselves
meantime you've got to talk about this
the record amounts of fentanyl the
deadly drug continues to be smuggled
into the Homeland 96 percent officials
say through Mexico contributing to
skyrocketing number of deaths across the
country researchers at the University of
Houston working on a fentanyl vaccine a
series of three shots that causes you to
produce fentanyl antibodies which
prevent the drug from entering a
person's brain in turn taking away the
euphoric high and all of the
life-threatening side effects along with
it scientists hope to begin human trials
on that vaccine in a couple of months
Harris
Casey Siegel thank you very much